este viernes parís acoge una reunión
exprés entre el presidente francés
emmanuel macrón la canciller alemana
angela merkel y el presidente ucraniano
volodymyr de lenski con el objetivo de
reducir las tensiones entre ucrania y
rusia en medio de preocupaciones sobre
un aumento del conflicto y la situación
en la región de donbass está bajo
control hay desafíos allí pero estamos
listos para responder a esos desafíos el
ejército está listo sin totana y es lo
más importante
un repunte en los combates desde
comienzos de año ha hecho que kiev y
moscú se culpen mutuamente por el
aumento de la violencia entre las
fuerzas gubernamentales y las
separatistas en las regiones de donets y
lugansk donde el conflicto entre las dos
facciones ha provocado ya más de 14.000
muertes desde 2014 el encuentro de fe
lenski con los líderes de francia y
alemania- mediadores del conflicto desde
2015 se produce después de que ucrania
acusar a rusia de amenazar su condición
de estado independiente y los temores de
una escalada han aumentado todavía más
con la presencia de miles de tropas
rusas se dice que se han reunido cerca
de la frontera oriental
ocupada nuestros diplomáticos en buscó y
piden a los socios que no distorsionen
la realidad que no intenten interpretar
las actividades militares rusas
planeadas que se llevan a cabo en
territorio ruso como manifestaciones de
intenciones agresivas su gran en las
últimas tensiones llegan en un momento
en el que las relaciones entre estados
unidos y rusia han empeorado esta semana
la casa blanca expresó su apoyo público
a ucrania y anunció nuevas sanciones
contra rusia y la expulsión de varios
diplomáticos
moscú prometió una respuesta rápida